Reviews are pouring in for Dark Phoenix, the
second cinematic attempt to adapt the classic
Marvel storyline of the same name, and they
are, for the most part, not good.
The flick is currently hovering just above
20 percent on Rotten Tomatoes.
What happened?
Dark Phoenix focuses on a serious problem
faced by the X-Men: how to deal with beloved
team member Jean Grey when she is imbued with
a mysterious, cosmic "Phoenix Force" which
overwhelms her to destructive results.
The storyline was featured as a subplot in
2006's X-Men: The Last Stand, in case this
sounds strangely familiar.
The film is the directorial debut of longtime
X-Men franchise producer Simon Kinberg, and
judging by the reviews, it's easy to see how
the film's failure could be chalked up to
his inexperience.
With a talented cast and a story that is the
stuff of legend in comics lore, Kinberg managed
to turn in a picture that Rotten Tomatoes'
Critics Consensus calls, quote, "deeply disappointing."
Writing for York Dispatch, Katie Walsh was
particularly irked by the performance of the
film's lead, Sophie Turner.
Walsh wrote:
"Kinberg asks her to be a sledgehammer, requiring
her to shout every emotional beat and turn,
relentlessly hammering the themes and messaging."
The critic also reserved plenty of scorn for
the flick's script.
"What's truly amazing about Dark Phoenix is
watching the charismatic, award-winning, star-packed
cast flail about in this poorly written nonsense
cartoon...perhaps [its worst offense] is proving
what X-Men: Apocalypse started in its treatment
of Oscar Isaac.
Despite the caliber and talent of the actor,
lackluster writing, directing, and editing
can warp a performance into something truly
dreadful.
Now that's power."
That tone continues throughout the reviews,
with many viewers lamenting how curiously
flat Dark Phoenix felt, despite its emotional,
high-stakes story.
William Bibbiani of The Wrap wrote:
"Turner [tries] with some success to infuse
the simplistic and irrational storyline with
some humanity, but everyone else looks like
they're more interested in what craft service
made for lunch that day...it's just a disappointingly
average superhero flick, with a familiar story,
disinterested actors, some cool action sequences,
and a whole lot of missed opportunities."
Business Insider's review also took notice
of the fact that the cast looks kind of bored
with the entire enterprise.
"Uhhh, so boring."
That review stated:
"Even the characters who have been around
since X-Men: First Class can't keep things
exciting.
[Jennifer] Lawrence as Mystique looks like
she'd rather be somewhere else."
Of course, not all reviewers agreed with the
consensus, although even the positive reviews
took care to point out the film's many flaws.
Forbes' Mark Hughes wrote that the movie was
an acceptable, if not amazing, end to the
series.
His review stated:
"While [Dark Phoenix] is not among the best
X-Men movies, it's not among the worst either.
It is safely in the middle range of 'okay,'
flawed but with some things to praise and
overall managing to maintain the status quo
without improving it nor tanking it...Unfortunately,
Dark Phoenix continued to decline in quality
through the back half of its second act, with
choppy editing and a lot of 'why would they
do that?' or 'why wouldn't they do this instead?'
moments."
Most observers, however, were firmly in the
consensus camp, and more than a few were downright
hostile.
In perhaps the most blistering takedown leveled
at the film, Clint Worthington of The Spool
wrote,
"Dark Phoenix is a film in mourning, of its
characters, its franchise, even of its own
previously pristine state before delays and
reshoots turned it into a Frankenstein's monster
of its former self...It's a franchise that
sees its own death coming, at one point, our
heroes are captured by military personnel
who literally have the letters 'MCU' emblazoned
on their gear, and greets it with a resigned
sigh.
For that reason at least, Dark Phoenix carries
a morbid fascination."
It's a good point.
The movie could still leave fans excited for
the future, if not exactly for the reasons
the filmmakers wanted.
Marvel Studios' parent company, Disney, having
recently acquired the film and television
assets of Fox Studios, is in an excellent
position to rehabilitate these characters
within the Marvel Cinematic Universe in the
years to come.
So despite this movie's lousy reception, maybe
the future of the X-Men isn't so dark after
all.
"Just because someone stumbles, loses their
way, it doesn't mean they're lost forever."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.